Dancing with the Stars delivers
show-stopping routines as two
contestants are eliminated boys to men
star Wanya Morris slayed with this
passionate Paso Doble then he performed
a fast-paced Charleston that earned him
yet again a perfect score still though
all that fancy footwork wasn't enough to
keep the singer in the competition he
and NFL pro Antonio Brown were sent home
it's like sailing a playoff game and
knowing you lost the game and you have
to go home but it's been an amazing
journey and one to be grateful for the
three remaining couples Paige and Mark
ginger and Val and nyle and Peeta who
earned straight tens with this Argentine
tango that the deaf model danced with a
blindfold been blindfolded oh good I
felt like a lot of people felt I felt
the energy and how people reacted to it
and that was the goal he really had to
be in so in tune with me to not have a
misstep and he did it for UFC fighter
Paige Vanzant there seem to be some heat
on and off the dance floor with troupe
member Alan Burstyn what is going on
between you and this fine bird
I don't know you got to ask him you were
asked about your chemistry with Alan and
you said yeah there is some chemistry
what exactly is that chemistry who knows
a girl does not give themselves well you
kind of put it on Alan's to tell you're
like let him answer the question how
come you two that it's a man's job he's
got to step up